angular is a full-fledged javascript
front-end framework used to create
single-page applications applications
like gmail upwork nike and forbes among
others are built using angular
now there's a great demand for angular
developers in the market today
so if you wish to learn angular then
you're in the right place
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already
make sure to click the subscribe button
and the bell icon to never miss an
update
in this session we're going gonna cover
the topic of what is angular i'm sure
all of you use mobile and web
applications be it from social media to
health care e-commerce and net banking
these apps are used by billions of
people across the globe now the main
reason we use these apps is that they
offer seamless user experience and
interface but how are they developed to
provide such reliability one of the
frameworks that is widely used to build
such robust apps is angular so let's
dive into the session now so here is a
list of topics that we're going to be
covering
first up we'll see why angular was
introduced
then what is angular
features of angular
angular architecture
advantages and limitations of angular
the learning curve of angular and
finally we'll look at some of the
companies that deploy angular so without
further delay let's begin
why angular now javascript is the most
commonly used client-side scripting
language it is written into html
documents enabling interactions with web
pages in many unique ways
so as a relatively easy to learn
language with almost pervasive support
it is exceptionally well suited to
develop modern applications but the
question arises
is javascript ideal for developing
single page applications that require
modularity testability and other
features perhaps not however we have a
variety of frameworks and libraries
designed to help us with such things
with respect to front-end development
angular and javascript together bring in
structure and consistency to your web
applications
and also provide scalability and
maintainability
angular is specifically developed for
single page applications so now the
question arises what exactly is angular
angular is an open source javascript
framework written completely in
typescript
now it was primarily aimed to develop
single page applications and is
maintained by google
angular as a framework provides a few
advantages while also providing a
standard structure for developers it is
designed for web desktop and mobile
platforms if you have a doubt here as to
what exactly single page applications
are let me help you with that now these
single page applications are basically
applications that get loaded just once
so the main page gets loaded onto your
browser so any further interactions does
not lead to loading of subsequent pages
anything that has to be done further is
just an addition to the already loaded
page so these single page applications
are primarily developed using angular
moving ahead let's look at the features
of angular
we have four features that we're going
to be discussing
we have the document object model type
script data binding and testing now
let's look at them one by one now the
document object model treats an xml or
an html document as a tree structure
now here every node in the tree
structure defines an object representing
a part of your document
angular uses the regular dom now let's
suppose you've made 10 updates on a
single html page
so every time you make a change the
corresponding dom or the tree structure
needs to be updated
now angular updates the entire tree
structure of html tags
moving on to our next feature
we have typescript
now typescript defines a set of types to
javascript which helps you write
javascript that is easier to understand
now all the typescript code compiles
down to basic javascript that can run
smoothly on any platform now typescript
is not mandatory for developing an
angular application but it is highly
recommended the main reason is highly
recommended is that it offers better
syntactic structure while making the
code base easier to understand and
maintain now typescript can be installed
as an npm package now to do that you
just have to run the command npm install
hyphen g type script on your command
prompt next up is data binding now data
binding is a process that allows you to
manipulate web page elements using the
web browser now it mainly employs
dynamic html and does not require
complex scripting or programming
it is used in web pages that include
interactive components like calculators
tutorials games etc now incremental
display of a web page makes data binding
extremely convenient when pages contain
a large amount of data when it comes to
angular it uses two-way data binding so
any changes meeting the ui element is
reflected in the corresponding model
state
and conversely any changes made in the
model state
are reflected onto the ui state
this allows the framework to connect the
dom to the model data via the controller
the last feature we're discussing is
testing
angular uses jasmine to run its various
tests the jasmine framework allows
various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases
karma is a task runner for the tests
that use a configuration file to set the
startup reporters and testing framework
so with that we've covered the features
of angular
so let's go ahead and understand
the architecture of angular
angular is a full-fledged mvc framework
it provides a strong opinion on how the
application should be structured and
offers bi-directional data flow and
updates to real dom mvc short for model
view controller is an architectural
pattern that separates the application
layer into model view and controller
model here relates to all the data
related logic
view on the other hand is used for ui
logic of the application
and controller is the brain of the setup
now it is an interface between the model
and view
moving on let's look at the advantages
of angular
first up we have custom components
angular allows you to build your own
components that can pack functionality
along with rendering logic into reusable
pieces
data binding as discussed
angular allows you to effortlessly move
your data from your javascript code to
the view and react to user events
without having to write any code
yourself
dependency injection angular allows you
to write modular services and have them
injected wherever they are needed
this greatly improves the testability
and reusability of the same don't worry
if you can't wrap your head around these
topics we're going to discuss them
further in the coming videos
next advantage is testing angular has
been built from the ground up with
testability in mind
you can literally test every part of
your application
comprehensive angular is a full-fledged
framework and provides out-of-the-box
solutions for server communication
routing and more
lastly we have excellent browser
compatibility angular is cross platform
and browser compatible an angular
application can typically run on all
browsers
be it chrome firefox safari
and platforms like windows mac os and
linux
now many versions of angular have been
released ever since its inception all of
these versions have added to the
efficient working of the framework now
here are two different versions released
first up was angular 1. it was built on
javascript and completely based on
controllers next release was angular 2.
now this incorporated the component
based approach wherein the entire ui was
divided into several components and
lastly integrated to give the final
logic
next was angular 4 it included router
updation angular cli or command line
interface 1.0 was introduced however not
deployed
in this release the angular cli was
optimized and commands like ng update
and ng add were added
in the angular 7 release prompts were
introduced which provided tips in cli
about the functions being used
in angular 8 iv renderer and bazel were
introduced
and finally the most recent release was
angular 9. now this came with the better
framework and angular material now this
completely switched to the iv renderer
as a default compiler now that we've
learnt about the pros of using angular
let's look at some of the limitations of
angular
first up is a sleep learning curve now
since angular is a complete full-fledged
framework it becomes difficult for
learners to begin with
you need to be acquainted with simple
topics and then move on to more advanced
topics to become proficient in this
language
next up is limited seo options
now angular offers limited seo options
and poor accessibility to search engine
crawlers
it's verbose and complex
now a common issue faced by the angular
community is the verbosity of the
framework
it also poses to be complex compared to
other front-end tools and lastly
migration now one of the drawbacks of
angular is poor migration
now it becomes difficult to port legacy
code to angular style architecture
also with each new release it is painful
to upgrade and a lot of them are not
backward compatible
next up let's look at the angular
learning curve
now if you wish to learn angular you
need to be acquainted with basic topics
in angular
some of them are directives
modules declarators components services
dependency injection
pipes and templates
now once you've mastered your basics you
will want to go and understand more
advanced topics such as change detection
zones aot compilation and rx.js
however the learning curve of angular is
clear cut
in the beginning it could be a little
intimidating but once you start using
the tool it becomes way more easier to
comprehend and understand what is going
on
and lastly let's look at some of the
companies that use angular today
many top tier companies like nike
forbes google hbo sony upwork among
others readily deploy angular so moving
on let's look at the prerequisites for
angular
first up we have node.js angular uses
node.js as its base for a large part of
its build environment
so as a result to get started with
angular you will need to have nodejs
installed on your environment so head to
their official website and download the
latest release for your corresponding
operating system
next up is the angular cli now this
command line interface is a tool that
makes it easier to bootstrap and develop
your angular applications now to install
the latest version run the command npm
install hyphen g
at angular front slash cli you got to
run this command on your command prompt
and finally to confirm installation
check for its version
now the next thing that you will need is
an ide or a text editor to type your
code now there are several ides that you
can choose from but in this series we've
used vs code throughout so it is
available on all platforms so go ahead
and download it if you haven't already
now moving on to the final part is the
demo now that you have a basic
understanding of angular and its
prerequisites i think you're ready to
create your first angular application
so let's head to our vs code and begin
here i've created a folder called
angular on my desktop and opened it on
my visual studio code so to create your
app you need to open the terminal just
go here and
select new terminal
and now type in the command
ng
new
and provide the name for your app so i'm
just going to say hello world
so now this is going to create
just say yes
so basically what happens is that when
you run the command it will
automatically generate a skeleton
application under the folder that is
hello world in our case
and it includes a bunch of files and
installs all the necessary dependencies
for the angular application
so this could take a while
so once you've created your application
to run it first change the directory so
let's say cd
hello world
and now use the command ng serve
now once it's compiled you need to go to
your browser and type in localhost 4200.
and once you do that
you can see your ui
you can see that the application has
been loaded onto your browser
and it says hello world app is running
so this is how you create your
application
so let's go back to our vs code now as
you can see here
there are many files and folders that
are created right so let's look at a few
of them of course we can't explain
everything but i'll rush through a few
of them
so the first main component is basically
the root component now the root
component here is the index.html
so here if you open the file and see
it's a very small crisp code right but
the most important thing in the file is
this app root element
so what this does is it's basically the
marker for loading your application code
so this is extremely important so the
next important file is the main.ts
now this is a part of the bootstrapping
piece all right so the index.html file
is responsible for deciding which files
are to be loaded correct the
file on the other hand identifies which
angular module is to be loaded when the
application starts so this is just a
brief explanation as to what they are
doing
next we have the app folder
now here we have the
app.module.ts file now this application
module file can be thought of as the
code configuration of your application
so here's where the source code starts
from and moving on we have the app.com
these are all typescript files hence the
extension ts now this file basically is
a root component of your application
and then we have the html file for the
same which defines the appearance of
what you can see on your browser so let
me just change the message that is being
displayed
so i'll say hey
welcome to this
angular
tutorial so let's save this and when we
go back to our browser
we can see the message hey welcome to
this angular tutorial being displayed
so like this we can make a simple change
and then it gets rendered onto your
browser so this was just a brief
explanation of what happens in the
background of your application
first we'll get acquainted to what
exactly angular components are
then i'll help you create an angular
component by showing a quick demo and
lastly we'll learn about component
decorator metadata but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our channel if
you love watching new and interesting
technology videos also hit the bell icon
to never miss an update so what exactly
are angular components
now i'm sure everybody uses web
applications and one of the most widely
used applications is gmail correct now
to help you understand what components
are consider them as lego blocks now
they basically are combined together to
form the final application
so in this case here we have the logo
component then you have a sign in
component
an image component and then a create
account component now all of these
components generally don't affect the
working of each other
but however when embedded they define
the ui of your application
so i hope you understood what components
are
so to go ahead let's discuss some of its
common features now firstly they are the
building blocks of an application
generally you have a root component
which is basically the app component and
then it branches out into other
components creating a hierarchy
and these components are a subset of
directives now don't worry about what
detectives are because we'll cover them
later on in the series but to give you
an idea there are three types of
directives you have the structural
directives the attribute directives and
the component directives
only one component can be instantiated
per element in a template now components
are typically custom html elements and
each of these elements can instantiate
only one component
now don't worry you'll understand this
better when i show you the demo
nextly a typescript class is used to
create a component now this class is
then decorated with the at component
decorator now the decorator accepts a
metadata object that gives information
about the component now a component must
belong to the ng module in order for it
to be usable by another component or
application
and finally components control their
runtime behavior by implementing life
cycle hooks
so this was just a brief introduction to
what angular components are
now you will only be able to understand
the working of components when i show it
to you practically so let's head over to
a visual studio code now here back in my
vs code i've created a folder called
angulardemo within which i've created an
angular application called demo
components
once executed the browser looks
something like this
so if you haven't watched our previous
video on getting started with angular
that is angular hello world i highly
suggest you go through that video first
it helps you create your first angular
application so um
now let's go ahead and create our first
component now the command used to create
our component is ng gc and your
component name
once executed it creates four different
files now let's just see how this works
on rvs code now what you can do is head
to your terminal and type in the command
ng
g
c
and provide a name for your component
for example i'm going to just call my
component text component all right
so what it does is that it creates four
different files you can see you have
four different files that have been
created and finally it updates the file
that is app.module.ts
indicating that this new component has
been created so here in your source
folder
within which there's an app folder and
again here you can see that your four
different files have been created first
is the html file where you can define
all the code that you want for your
component next you have the css file for
your styling
then you have the dot ts file which
includes the component decorator and
finally you have spec.ts which is
basically a unit test file all right and
then in your app.module.ts
you can observe that the component that
you've created that is text component
has been imported that is what the
message conveys here all right now let's
go back to our app.component.html
now this basically has all the code for
your application so let me just get rid
of it
[Music]
and i'm just gonna
display a basic
heading saying
hello
welcome
all right so let me save it
and if you go ahead and look at your
browser
hello welcome message is displayed now
let's go back to our component
dot html file
and here
let me
provide a message
[Music]
let me say h
three
and let me display a message saying
welcome to this tutorial
on angular components
all right
now in your text
component.ts file which is your
typescript file
the selector mentioned here is app
hyphen text component now go ahead and
copy this
and in your final
component.html go ahead and create your
custom html tag with the selector that
you just copied now this indicates that
the component that you just created that
is the text component is being
incorporated in the final render so what
happens is that whatever is defined in
the component.html file is also being
rendered in your final output so when i
save this
let's go ahead and check
our browser you can see that the message
welcome to this tutorial on angular
components is displayed
so this was a simple creation of a
component now for this let's give it
some styling
so here go to your dot css file and
provide some styling
say for example here i just say
text line
and let me say center and also in my
app.component.cs i'm going to give the
same thing
and say each one
text align
is center
all right so let me save this
and there we go
now we can also create multiple
components and define the tags in the
app component now the components are
executed sequentially so now let's
create another component just to give
you a brief insight into it let's say
nggc
image component
now here i'm going to be adding the
simply learn logo so i'll show you how
that works
now you can see that a new component has
been created with four files again so in
my assets folder here i've added the
logo
so what i can do is back in my html file
i can go ahead and create an image tag
so first let me just display another
message here
just to avoid any confusion and let me
say this is the image component
[Music]
and then
let me say
image
source
equals so the source is basically assets
[Music]
slash
logo
dot png
and class
equals
center
[Music]
all right so you can also head to your
css file and provide any sort of styling
that you need
so let me just say
text
align
to be center
and then let's create
a styling for the image
and here i mentioned the code for the
image
so let's save this and from the dot cs
file
let's copy the selector
and create a custom html tag in our
final component.html file
so there we go
let's save this and check the output
and there we go
first the hello welcome message is
displayed
next you have the message displayed from
the first component and then you have
the second component
so this is how you can create your own
components and don't forget to
incorporate these selectors into your
final html file
so moving on to our next topic component
decorator metadata now as mentioned
earlier the at component decorator
accepts a metadata object that provides
information about the component
correct here is a list of properties of
the metadata object first up is the
selector now basically the selector is a
css selector that identifies this
particular component in a template now
this corresponds to the html tag that is
included in the parent component you can
create your own html tag however the
same has to be included in the parent
component so to help you understand that
better let's head back to our vs code
and say for example in our text
component
here
the selector says text component
correct for the time being let's change
it to say n component
[Music]
all right
now when you save it and look at the
browser
the message is not displayed
so what we can do is you can copy this
selector
and then include this
here
and now you can see
that the same component has been
rendered onto your output
all right so the selector plays a
crucial role in that
next up we have the template now a
template is an inline defined template
for the view now the template can be
used to provide some particular markup
the markup could typically include some
headings or paragraphs that are
displayed on the ui
next up we have template url now it is
the url for the external file containing
the template for the view
so here you can see
this is basically the external file that
contains the template for the view
next up you have styles now these are
also inline defined styles that can be
applied to the components view so any
code that you provide in the dot css
file can also be included here
next you have the style urls now this is
a list of urls to your style sheets that
are applied on your components view
next up you have providers now this is
again an array where certain services
can be registered for your component
lastly we have animations as the name
suggests these are animations that can
be listed for your components
in today's session we're going to learn
all about angular data binding
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update
so now without further ado let's begin
so here's what's in store for you
first we'll understand what exactly data
binding is
next
we'll understand the types of data
binding that is interpolation and
property binding
event binding and two-way data binding
so let's begin
what exactly is data binding now i'm
sure you must have heard the term data
binding quite often now data binding is
what is responsible to ensure
consistency between the view and your
component so it allows an internet user
to manipulate all the web page elements
in the web browser
and it employs dynamic html and does not
require any sort of complex scripting or
programming
it is generally used for web pages that
contain interactive components like
calculators tutorials and games
and lastly it ensures incremental
display of a web page
now in simple terms what i'm saying is
that data binding ensures that any
change made in the ui of the application
is also reflected in the component and
vice versa
by doing so data binding ensures
consistency throughout the application
so now let's have a look at the
different types of data binding
first up we're going to be learning
about interpolation and property binding
next even binding and then the two-way
data binding
so what exactly is interpolation and
property data binding
now when it comes to interpolation
binding it ensures that the values are
reflected from the components to the dom
in this technique text representing
variables and components are placed
between double curly braces in the
template
so angular finds the variable matching
the text in the component and replaces
the text with the actual value assigned
to that particular variable so this
could be numbers strings etc
so to understand this better let's look
at a simple demo
back in my vs code i've created a simple
angular project and then created a
folder called binding all right and i've
displayed the message welcome on the
screen here so now in my component.ts
file i'll create
a variable
let's call it
name
say public
name
equals and i'm going to assign the value
simply learn to it
all right and here in my html for
interpolation what i'm going to do is
i'm as mentioned earlier i'll have to
include the variable name within curly
braces right so i'll say welcome
to
and within curly braces i'm just going
to say
name all right and to just beautify the
code i'll just center align everything
and just say style
now here in the browser we can see
welcome to simply learn being displayed
as you can see this part is being
replaced by the value of the variable
name which is simply learn
all right we can also add another one
let's just
create another variable
and
saying public
i'm going to say topic
and let me see data binding
all right and in my html file
i'll create
now i'm going to display another message
saying welcome to
the
topic
tutorial
so topic here must be replaced by its
value all right so let's see that
so let me just save this and have a look
at the browser
so here you can see that welcome to the
data binding tutorial is being displayed
so this is a simple example of
interpolation binding
so now moving on to property binding now
again property binding is a one-way
mechanism that lets you set the property
of a view element
now it involves updating the value of a
property in the component and binding it
to an element in the view template
and property binding uses the square
braces syntax for data binding
so now let's have a look at the simple
demo so now i'm going to be creating an
image variable
and i'm going to provide the path to my
logo.png in my assets folder so let me
just say
slash assets
slash logo.png
right
and now back in my html file
i will create a simple image tag
image and then i'm going to use property
binding for the source property
and
source equals image
all right and now just to beautify the
code i'm just going to provide some
styling
with some height and width
and i've also provided the css styling
for center
so now once once you save the file and
have a look at the browser
you can see that the image is being
displayed with the help of property data
binding
now you could argue that instead of
using property binding you could have
just used interpolation binding now
however there is one drawback using
interpolation binding interpolation
binding can only be used for string
values when you want to bind boolean
values
property binding is a better option next
up we have even binding
so this data binding type is used when
information flows from the view to the
component when an event is triggered
so what happens is that
the view sends the data from an event
like the click of a button to be used to
update the component it is the exact
opposite of property binding where the
data goes from the component to the view
so again the event could be a mouse
click or a key press so now let's head
to vs code so here i'm going to be
creating a button for the click event
all right so let's just create a button
okay and i'm gonna display the message
subscribe
to simply learn on it
all right and the event is going to be a
click event so let me say
click
and i'm going to pass
a function called on click
all right
so what happens is that when the button
is clicked this particular method is
called
so now let's define the method in our
component.ts file
so here i'll say
on click
i'm going to just display a console
message
saying thank you
for subscribing
okay
so what happens is that i'm binding the
click event to the on click method and
every time the user clicks on this
button the message is displayed so now
let's have a look at the browser let's
just inspect this first
all right in my console
now when i click on the button
you can see the message thank you for
subscribing is displayed so this is how
even binding is achieved
and lastly let's have a look at two-way
data binding now two-way data binding is
a mechanism where data flows from
the component to the view and back
the component and view are always in
sync and the changes made on either ends
will immediately update both ways
now two-way data binding is typically
used when dealing with forms where the
user input is used to update the
component state and vice versa
so let's have a look at the
demo
let me just center align this
first let's say
div
okay
all right so first i'm going to be
creating a property
and let's just call it
public
value and i'm going to just
initialize it to nothing
all right
and back in my html i'm going to create
an input tag
of type
text and i'm going to bind the value
using interpolation
all right
so basically what we're doing is that
every time the user provides a value in
the input box that has to be reflected
in the model as well so we're making
sure that the view and the model are in
sync and to make sure this happens we
have to make use of the ng model
directive
so for that i'm just going to provide ng
model now one thing to remember is that
we have to make use of banana in a box
styling for it so first i'm going to
make use of parentheses
and then square brackets
and this needs to be initialized to
value
all right so let's save this
so in the browser when i provide a text
in my input
box you can see that nothing below is
being displayed whatever in the text box
whatever i provide in the text box needs
to be displayed
but although we've used the ng model
directive here it still does not display
the message that is because ng model
directive is a part of the forms module
so you have to go ahead and
import that in your module.ts file so
here just say import forms module form
from angular forms
and just provide it in your imports add
a
say forms module
save this
all right and now let's have a look at
the browser
so when i provide
anything
the same is being displayed down
which means that our model and our view
are in complete sync this is how two-way
data binding is achieved first we'll
have a look at what's in store for us
first we'll understand what exactly
dependency injection is
then we'll understand the demerit or the
drawback of not using dependency
injection then we'll understand
dependency injection as a design pattern
and finally i'll help you understand the
entire concept with the help of a demo
so let's begin
what exactly is dependency injection so
let's consider this i'm sure you're
aware that angular uses the concept of
components the entire ui of the
application is divided into several
components
now what if all of these components
perform similar tasks be it accessing
the database rendering images etc now
instead of writing the same piece of
code for every component you could write
the code once and then perhaps inject
the same code into every component
now this is supported by dependency
injection now to give you a better
example consider two classes a and b
now let's assume that a uses the objects
of class b
and normally in object oriented
programming an instance of class b is
created so that a can access its objects
but using dependency injection we move
the creation and binding of dependent
objects outside of the class that depend
on them so dependency injection or di
keeps the core more flexible testable
and mutable also classes can inherit
external logic without having to create
on its own
and lastly gi benefits directives pipes
and components
next up let's have a look at the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
now let's consider class postal details
that is dependent on the number and the
address class
in the postal details class the
constructor creates copies of the number
and address
so when you instantiate a new postal
details class the constructor
instantiates a unique number and address
now although this looks simple there's a
problem with this code
let's assume that the number and address
class constructors now accept parameters
when we change the numbers class the
postal details class gets broken
now to overcome this what we need to do
is we need to pass parameter to the
number constructor so this applies to
address as well
the first drawback of using this
traditional method is that the code is
not very flexible
anytime the dependencies change the
postal details class needs to be changed
as well
and the second drawback is that the code
is not suitable for testing
once you instantiate the new postal
details class you get the same number
and address even if you change the
number and address classes every time
what if these classes are in turn
dependent on other classes
then it's going to be a chain reaction
so to overcome this we make use of
dependency injection
now let's look at di as a pattern
dependency injection as you all know is
a coding pattern where a class receives
its dependencies from an external source
rather than creating them on its own so
here in the above example we have moved
the definition of dependencies from
inside the constructor to the
constructor's parameters
so the postal details class doesn't
create the dependencies anymore
it just consumes them so the postal
dependencies class doesn't create the
dependencies anymore
so with that we overcome the drawbacks
of not using di
so now that you know what exactly
dependency injection is and how vital it
is let's look at a simple demonstration
to understand the concept better
now services classes modules competence
all of these are benefactors of
dependency injection so in the demo i'm
going to be showing how dependency
injection can be used with the help of
services and injecting these services
into classes so the main
thought behind this is normally
components are used to ensure just a
good user experience
these components do not generally
execute tasks so to execute these tasks
we make use of services so a component
can delegate tasks like fetching data
from the server any network related
issues etc to a particular service and
these services can be made available to
components
with the same thought what i'm going to
be doing is i'll be creating a service
that performs the task of displaying an
employee list
later we're going to inject the service
into the class using dependency
injection
so let's head to our visual studio code
for the demonstration
all right so as discussed i'll have to
first create a component that displays a
button for the employee and then i have
to create a service class and inject it
into my component now this service holds
the employee details such as name
employee id email id etc
so first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here let me just type
nggc
and the name of the component i'm
providing is amp
info
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
alright so as you can see here in my app
folder i have the component
with four different files
all right so the next thing we have to
do is we have to create a service so to
create that we make use of the command
ng g
s
you can either give s or service and the
service name i'm providing is records
so let me just say
records here
all right here you can see two files are
created there is a spec.ts file and the
dot ts file
all right so now the service contains
all the employee data that needs to be
displayed right so let's go ahead and
write the data so first we're going to
make use of three arrays i'm going to be
displaying employee records for three
employees so i'll have to create three
arrays and provide certain information
so let's go ahead and do that
all right so the area i'm creating is
called info one for the first employee
and i'm going to be
passing
information like name employee id and
the email id
so the arrays of type string
and within which let me just mention the
details i'm giving random information
i'm just saying adam taylor
and some random
employee id
and let's say 80 at abc.net
all right so i'm going to be creating
three records so i'll just copy the same
thing and paste for the rest too
let's just change here
provide a different name here
and same for the last one
and
let me change the name of the area as
well
all right so with the agenda to retrieve
this data in our component we make use
of the method for the same right so this
method returns the employee data
so let's go ahead and create this method
i'm going to call it get info
and then just say string
and then this will just return
this dot in four one
all right i'm going to be calling it get
info 1 for better understanding
same for the rest 2 as well
i'm just going to return different
arrays here
all right and lastly info 3 all right
now in order to retrieve this
information in our component we need
three more arrays right three more
arrays that will receive this data let's
go back to our component dot ts file
here
and then type in the following code
so i've created three arrays again or
info received one two and three now what
we need to do is we have to accept the
information that is being sent from the
service correct
now as
i mentioned services are implemented
with the help of dependency injection so
what we need to do is we'll have to
first import the service into the
component.ts file
the key reason behind doing this is that
when angular creates this component an
instance of the service class is also
made to perform the necessary tasks
correct so let's go ahead and just
import it here
so i'll say import
[Music]
records
services
i'm sorry service
from
and let's say records.service
all right and what we have to do next is
that we must also declare this instance
that is being created in the providers
area of the component
all right so
let's just say providers
and then say records
service
all right now we've created the instance
of this class right however to access
this instance an object is also created
so this object will in turn access the
methods and variables of the service
class so for that we have to create
another object so let's do that here in
our constructor method
let's say constructor
private
and the object i'm creating is called
our service you can give a name
of your choice and then i'm going to
just say records
service
all right now this
object will help me retrieve data from
the service so let's go ahead and use
this in order to get the employee
details
all right i've created three different
methods here get info from service class
2 1 and 3 and these methods will
retrieve the data and add it to our
array here that is info received all
right
and lastly
we'll have to create an unordered list
in our html file here we haven't added
anything so let me get rid of this
so now i have to create three different
buttons for three different employees
and when the user clicks on the button
the data is retrieved from the service
and then displayed on the ui
right
so as you can see i've created buttons
for three different employees
and then i've made use of a bootstrap
class called list group info
and then i've
interpolated
info which displays the contents
of the info variable all right now in
order to call the methods in the dot ts
file we have to bind them with the
button
so since it is bound with the click
event every time you click on the button
the information is
displayed
so now the last thing we have to do is
we'll have to create a custom html tag
for the component and then add it to the
main component
so let's just do that
let me copy
this here
and then in my
appcomponent.html let me get rid of this
and then let me just create this
i've just created the custom html tag
for my component
and now just to beautify the code i'll
write a heading
and let's say
employee
details
and then i'll also add the simply learn
logo
say image source
[Music]
i've i've added the image here so let me
just say logo
dot png
i've also added some styling to it
all right so now let me just save this
and have a look at the browser
so here we go we have the logo here and
then employee details heading and then
we have three different buttons created
that is employee one two and three and
when i click on it
the information of the employee is
displayed the name the id and their
email address
so yeah so this is how you can make use
of dependency injection and inject a
service class into a component
dependency injection plays a crucial
role in angular
i'm sure you all know that an angular
app is divided into several components
for example you have the logo component
you have the sign in component an image
component and say a create account
component
now these components are standalone
and each of them represents a part of
the user interface
now imagine if all of these components
performed common tasks for example
accessing the database
or rendering images on the view
tasks like those
now instead of having to write the code
for every component
you can just make use of angular
services
now the service can be written once and
they're injected into all of these
components
now a service could be a function it
could be a variable or a feature that an
application needs
so the main use of a service is to write
code once and avoid rewriting of it
now the same code can be injected into
several components that make use of this
particular service
but what are angular services
so normally components are used to
ensure a good user experience now that
is the extent of it
components make sure that whatever is
being rendered onto the screen is right
and pristine
but in order to execute tasks we make
use of services and this approach is
ideal
so a component can basically delegate
tasks like fetching data from the server
validating user input or logging
directly to the console to a particular
service
and these tasks can be made available to
any component in the app
so now let's talk about a few features
of angular services
now typically an angular service is
simply a typescript class with an at
injectable decorator
this decorator tells angular that the
class is a service and can be injected
into components that need that service
now they can be used to share the same
piece of code they can also inject other
services as dependencies
now these services hold valuable
business logic
and can also be used to interact with
the backend
now for example if you want to make ajax
calls you can have methods to those
calls in the service and then use it as
a dependency in files
and as mentioned earlier it can be used
to share data among several components
in angular services are singleton
meaning that only a single instance of a
service gets created and the same
instance is used by each and every
building block in the application and
finally a service can be registered as a
part of a module or it can be registered
as a part of the component now to
register it as a part of the component
you'll have to specify it in the
provider's array of the module
i'm sure you'll understand the concept
of services better if we look at a
simple demo
so in the next section we're going to
look at a demo but before that let me
tell you the use case
so basically in the demo what we'll do
is we'll create an employee details list
say for example you will have employee
information like name employee id and
their email id
will create a database of say three
employees
and on the browser when you click on the
employee button it displays the
information about that particular
employee
and at the end we can also add
information to the employee's details so
without delay let's head to our vs code
and start learning angular services
hands-on so here first i've created a
folder called demo underscore angular
within which i've created a file called
hello world
so this was previously used for a
tutorial so the name is just hello world
so don't get confused
however when you
look at the browser i've written
an initial code here
which is angular services and i have the
simply learn logo so back in my browser
this is what the ui looks like
so uh to
so to understand the concept of angular
services
first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here i'm going to say ng
g c
e info
i'm creating a component for employee
information
so as you can see
inside my app
file we have the e info
component which has these four files
so if you're wondering what exactly
components are and how this is working
then i highly suggest you watch our
competence video first
so now let's go ahead and create a
service
so i'm just typing in the command ng
g
service
here g stands for generate
and we're generating the service and the
name of the service that i'm providing
is data
so now it creates a service
which is going to be
a dot ts file
so you can observe that dot service is
appended this indicates that it is a
service
all right
as mentioned earlier we have to display
the employee details correct so for that
in my component.ts file i'm going to
create an array
that displays the employee information
in our case i'm creating uh three
different employee records so for that
i'll have three different arrays
so let me just call the arrays info
received
one indicating this is the information
of
first employee
and this is going to be of type string
and i'll just initialize it to null
for now
all right and i'm going to create
two other
arrays
and let me just
change
the name of the arrays all right
so now uh to retrieve the information
i'll have to create a method again i'm
creating three methods for the three
different employee records
so i'm gonna call the array get
info
[Music]
from service
one
indicating it's again for employee one
and
i'm just going to leave it as it is for
now i'll tell you how the information is
being received
and i'm gonna do the same for the other
two uh employee records so let me just
copy paste and here
i'm just going to change
the name of the methods
all right
so this is the initial code for
retrieving information
however we'll have to create the
employee record in our service
so back here in my data.ts file
what i'm going to do is i'll create
three different
records
for the employees
so let me say info 1
which is going to be of type string
all right
and
let me just give a random names say for
example i say john
matthew
[Music]
all right
and
employee id say
e
354
and let me just give a random
email id and say jm at abc.net
all right so i'm gonna do the same for
the other two uh records
so let me just create another one and
call it info 2
and
the name i'm providing is say rob
listen
with a different employee
id say 673
and i'm just gonna make it
rw at abc.net
and another record
for employee number three
and
i'm just gonna say rose adams
[Music]
with
some employee id
and
an email id all right
so now
we've created the employee records
so what i have to do is i have to create
a method
that returns these employee records
correct so for that
i'm just going to create another method
called get info 1
which is of type string
and it just returns
this dot info 1
all right
similarly for the rest of the two
records i'm just going to retrieve them
[Music]
let's say in 4 2
and get info 2
and again
i'm just going to make it get in for 3
and this is going to
return
four three
all right so i'm sure you've got an idea
as to what i'm doing here so basically
this information is going to be
retrieved in our employee component
correct so for that i'll have to make
use of dependency injection
so here i'll have to import the service
that i've created so let's go ahead and
say import
[Music]
the service was data service
all right
from
[Music]
slash data dot service all right now the
main reason we're doing this is to tell
angular that when the component is
created
the service instance is also created and
this instance is being used to perform
particular tasks
and for that we'll also have to include
this in our providers area
so here
let me just say providers
[Music]
and let's say data service
now to access this instance of service
that is created we make use of a
property
so this property basically allows us to
access all the methods that are defined
in the service class
all right
so here in my constructor method i'm
just going to say
private
and you can give any name for your
property and here i'm just giving the
name d service
all right
and which is of type
data service
all right
so now with the help of this property i
can retrieve information from the
service
class so here i'm just going to save
this
dot
info received
equals this dot
d service
dot
get info one
all right so what it basically does is
that it calls the get info one method in
our service
which returns the information of the
first employee
and this information is being stored in
the array that is info received one
so similarly for the next
two methods i'm just going to use the
same
piece of code
let me just change it here
and
same for the third one
all right
so now that we have the logic behind
what is being displayed let's go ahead
and create the ui for it
here in my html file
i'm going to create
an unordered list
[Music]
and now i'm going to make use of
the ng
for director
to uh basically loop over the record and
display everything
so for that i have to make use of a
particular variable so i'll just say
let info
of
info received
so um you can check here in our ts file
the
array is info received correct so i'm
going to make use of the same array here
and since it's displaying the first
employee record i'm just going to
say
info received one
all right and let me just create a class
a bootstrap class of list
group
item of list group info
and we're just going to have to
interpolate
in 4
all right that is basically going to
display what the information holds what
the info variable holds
all right and here as well let me create
a bootstrap class
called list
group
all right i hope this was clear to you
so basically here
the information is being retrieved with
the help of this method right that is
get info from service one so in order to
call this method we'll have to bind it
with a button all right so that's what
we're gonna do
let's
just copy this and here i'm going to
create a button
all right
and the type
is button
[Music]
with name
button again
all right so i'm going to bind it with
the click event
so what happens is that when i click on
it
this particular method gets called
all right i'm just pasting the method
here and finally let's just
provide the name employee 1
for the button
all right
so similarly we'll have to do the same
for
the other two records as well
let me just make this look better all
right
so what i'm gonna do is i'm just gonna
paste the same
twice
and here i'm gonna just change the names
i'll say 2 here
and this is again for employee 2
and i'm going to change this as well
it's going to be employee i'm sorry it's
going to be in 4 received 2 this is
going to be in 4 received 3
and finally employee 3
all right
and lastly we'll have to include
the selector that is app hyphen e info
in our main
component
or html so here
let me just
create a custom tag all right and save
this so now let's go back to our browser
and see what it looks like
so here you can see that three different
buttons have been created
for employee one two and three and when
you click on it
it retrieves information that is
the name the employee id and their email
ids so we've successfully created an
angular service and injected it into our
component to retrieve information all
right so now the last part of the use
case that we discussed
was uh to add another
detail that is the employee detail in
the record
all right so for that we'll have to take
uh input from the user and in our case
we're taking the location
now uh we're also adding the same
location for all three employees
so this is what services do you know
they can be used to update modify alter
anything that happens in the back end so
you can tweak the code a little bit
and you can change the entire uh view of
your application you can add information
you can delete you can retrieve you can
alter etc all right so for that what
we're going to do is back in the html
file we'll create a form
that basically takes the input so i'm
just going to say um
[Music]
form
all right
within which i'm going to be defining a
div class
[Music]
within which i'm going to be defining a
div tag
inside of which i'll have
the input tag
of type
text
and
the name i'm going to be providing it
will be location
all right
[Music]
and we'll have a value and i'll just
leave it blank and finally i'll have ng
model so if you're confused as to what
i'm doing here then i suggest you watch
the angular forms
video
it basically teaches you how to work
around with angular forms
all right and now
after this we're gonna have a button
so let me say button
[Music]
all right
[Music]
and i'm gonna just say add
info
okay
all right so now when i'm creating the
form i'll also have to create a
template variable to access all the
values within my form
so if i have to access the location then
i need a variable to access it so here
let me just go ahead and create a
template variable let me call it
frm
and i'm going to make use of the ng form
directive
so this tells angular
that
this variable can be used
to
access all the values within the form
and since i'm using form here
i'll have to import it in my
module
file
so here
i just go ahead
and say
import forms module from angular forms
and here in my imports
[Music]
i'll just say forms
module
okay so i've imported the forms module
so now back in my html file
what i'm going to do is that i'll have
to make use of this template variable
to update my information correct
so i'll have to create another method
that will update information into the
records
so here in my
component.ts file i'll have to create
another
method
and i'm going to call this method update
info method
all right
and uh this basically takes in the
template variable that is form
and let me just specify any
okay and what this is going to do
is that it updates
the record correct so i'm going to say
this
dot
d service
dot
add info
now you must be wondering what ad info
is
i'll just let you know in a minute and
and the value that i'm going to be
passing will be the value that you've uh
provided as an input which is nothing
but form
dot value dot location
all right so now what happens is that
i'll have to again specify what add info
is and this method is going to be
defined in the service uh file correct
so here
i'm going to create another um
method that's add
info
and i'm going to pass info as a
parameter and what this method does is
that it just pushes the information or
the data into the arrays
so since i'm going to be pushing the
same information into all of these
arrays that is info one in photo and
info three i'm just going to say this
dot info 1
dot push
off info
[Music]
all right and the same for
the other two areas as well
let me just
change these all right
so what exactly i'm doing is that i have
i have a method called add info which
gets information from the component
all right and it basically pushes this
information into the array and also i
have to return it so i'll say return
this dot info
[Music]
one
all right
and i'll save it
and here we have another method called
update info which basically calls uh the
add info method in our service and
passes the value to it
and in my html file
also note that the button type here is
submit
and not button
so what happens is that
now the value that we've received as an
input has to be
uh passed on to the method that is
update info so here
i'll say ng submit
and
i'm going to call the method
update
info
and i'm going to pass
frm
as
the argument
and now let's save this
and execute
so all right here you can see that we
have an input field and a button saying
add info
so now i can just go ahead and say type
usa
and when i say add info
and when i check on my
employee 1 details usa has been added to
the list
and same goes with employee 2 and
employee 3.
so i hope this simple demo on angular
services helped you understand the
concept better i highly recommend you
play around and explore other
possibilities
first we'll understand what angular
forms are
then we'll look at the different types
of form building supported by angular
next up we'll get acquainted with
features like form control and group
control
and we learn all of this with the help
of a simple demo
so without further ado let's begin
so what exactly are angular forms
now i'm sure every application that you
use comes with certain amount of form
filling correct be it your login
credentials or your sign up forms or any
sort of registration forms etc so forms
are an integral part of a web
application
you need forms to update your profile or
to enter sensitive information or also
to perform any sort of data related
tasks so now let's look at the different
types of form building supported by
angular
first up angular supports two types of
form building
first you have the template driven
approach and second you have the
reactive approach
now let's look at them one by one so
talking about template driven approach
in this method the conventional form tag
is used to create forms
so angular automatically interprets and
creates a form object with the help of
the directives
now controls can be added to the form
using the ng model tag
now multiple controls can be grouped
using the ng control group module so it
basically uses several module classes to
provide controls
now if you don't get this don't worry
you'll understand better when i'm
showing you the demo
next up is json values so form value can
be generated using the form dot value
object
form data is exported as json values
when the submit method is called
lastly basic html validations can be
used to validate the form fields in the
case of custom validations directives
can be used so arguably this method is
the simplest way to create an angular
form
so moving on to the active approach now
this approach is the programming
paradigm revolving around data flows and
propagation of change
now with reactive forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
now reactive forms are code driven
unlike template driven approach
reactive forms eliminate the anti
pattern of updating the data model by a
two-way data binding
so it does not use two-way data binding
and typically a reactive form control
creation is synchronous and can be unit
tested with synchronous programming
techniques
so now let's go ahead and look at form
control and form group
so consider a typical form consisting of
fields like name age and location
now a form control is basically a class
that enables validation of these fields
for each input field an instance of this
class is created
now these instances help check the
values of the field and see if they are
either touched untouched dirty pristine
valid invalid and so on so this allows
you to check every field for the value
it makes it easier to understand which
field's value is invalid or which field
has not been entered etc
now moving on to form group
so a form group class represents a group
of controls
a form can have multiple group controls
the form group returns true if all the
controls are valid and provides
validation errors if there are any so i
hope this was clear
so moving ahead let's look at the demo
to explain all of these features i'm
sure it will become extremely clear once
you look at the demo
so for that let's head to our vs code
so back in my vs code
i've created a component called form
component
and um i've also included the simply
learn logo just to beautify the
appearance so once you execute the code
this is what you're going to see on your
browser
so you just have the logo at the moment
the first thing we need to do is we'll
have to
import the forms module all right
so oh uh but before we begin let me tell
you what the use case is so we're going
to be creating a user registration form
which is going to include four fields
that is the first name last name email
id and a password
all right so now let me show you how to
import the forms module so in your main
app.module.ts file
you will have to import forms module
from angularforms
all right and then in your imports
you'll have to just call it here
all right so this is just a simple step
and now once you're done with that
let's go ahead and
start our form creation
so here in my component.html
let's enclose the entire form within a
div tag so here
let me say div
class
is a container
within which let me just have one
heading
it says user registration
all right and now let's go ahead and
create our form
so first let me just say form
now i'm going to create a div class for
every field
so
say div
class
equals form group
i'll explain it to you a little later
now first let's create a label
so label tag
for
basically it's the first name
so let me just say first name
and the tab will basically have
first name again
all right and let me just break the line
next we have the field so let's say
input
type is text
name
is first name
and we have a class which is
the form control class
all right
so this we have to do for all the other
fields
so let me just copy this
and
paste it like four times
i'll also add the tag three
for spacing
let's do that here
and finally we'll have the button
so let's just add that here
with a type
submit
let's just say submit on the button
so now let's go ahead and change these
values here
so here let me just change it to last
name
here as well
and here as well
and in this case it is going to be email
so let me just change it here
and finally we have passwords so
let's add that here
all right so let's save this and just
have a look at our browser
so there we go we have our
user registration form ready
but i would like to
align it to the center so let me just do
that
so here in my css file
i'm just going to uh
align all the div tags the center and
the label tag to the left so let me save
this and look at the browser now
and there we go we have our registration
form with a logo so this is how you
create a simple form
now we'll have to add a directive called
ng model
now this directive when added into the
input tag
will
provide form controls to every input
field
all right so here let's just go ahead
and say ng
model
that is it
so let me just copy this and paste it
for every other field
all right let me save this
and back in my browser
let me inspect
and here you can see different types of
classes like ng untouched ng pristine ng
ballot are added
right so this indicates that angular has
recognized the form tab
and it has added these classes to the
form as well as all the fields
so this is achieved when you add the ng
model directive in your input tag now
back in my vs code
now every form has an output property
attached to it called ng submit all
right so this property can be bound
within a method that method called the
sub bit method
so once submitted this method is called
right so once we click on the submit
button this method has to be called so
to include that
we'll have to just say
form
ng submit
equals
submit
[Music]
all right so now we have to define the
submit method
in our component.ts file so here let me
just go to our component.ts file and let
me
just get rid of unnecessary code here
and let's define a function
or submit
and then here let me just
console.log
form submitted
all right so let me just get rid of this
as well it's unnecessary here
let's save this so what it means is that
every time you click on the submit
button
this method is called all right so let's
just have a look at the browser so first
let's go to our console
and when i click on submit it says form
submitted
all right
so the next crucial step is to generate
javascript representation now we'll have
to make use of another directive called
ng form
that is assigned to a template variable
okay so
this javascript representation helps
with validating all the fields so i'll
help you understand that better
so back in our html file
let's just create a variable first
let's call it login
all right
and say ng
form
okay
now the mgform object includes the
javascript representation so now while
you're calling the submit method you're
going to pass login as a parameter
so let's just say login here
and in my ts file
again let's just say login
and along with it
i want login to be displayed so
i say login again
so now let's save this
and if you have a look at the browser
let's click on submit
and now here you can see the javascript
representation
so within form
i can
check
for
email
or say first name and here for this
field first name you can see different
properties attached you can see invalid
is it invalid or is it untouched
which is true or are there any errors so
this basically gives you all information
about the particular field
so we can make use of this feature to
validate the information so we're going
to learn about that in our next segment
moving on to form validation one way to
ensure that incorrect fields are not
submitted is by disabling the submit
button
correct now apart from this you can also
specify certain properties in your input
tag for the corresponding input field
now um let's say that the fields that
now let's say that the fields can't be
empty and the form only accepts names
with the minimum length of 2 and the
maximum length of 7
all right so here in my input tag
i just mentioned required meaning this
field cannot be empty
and min length
to 2
and
max length
to say 7
all right
so to check this
let's go to our browser
and here
let me submit the form without filling
the first name
and evidently there has to be an error
so when i submit
it and i look here
what's in forms and here controls
and my first name
you can see that
an error is shown here it says
required equals true
that means that there is one error
now you can make use of these form
control objects
you can leverage form control objects to
ensure field validation and display a
message whenever an error occurs
right so to do that you need to access
these objects like errors or invalid
or touched all of these properties or
objects need to be
accessed for that we'll have to create a
template variable
and then this variable is assigned to
this object
so back in our vs code
let's create
a variable
let me call it
name
and
let's say
ng
model
all right here the variable name
receives the control
object
so here back in my browser when i submit
again without
the first name
you can see that the invalid
property is set to true
correct so this helps us use this
property to alert the user with the help
of a simple if logic
so back in my
vs code
let me create
another
div tag
within which i mentioned ng if
within which i'm going to use a simple
if logic
so let's say mgf
name which is our template variable
name
dot touched
and
name dot invalid
is true
right then i'm going to alert
so i'm going to
make use of an alert
here let's say
alert danger
all right
so in my css file i'll have to
mention the simple styling for alert
so here let me just say
so we're going to have the background
color red
for
danger all right
and here i'm going to display the
message
invalid in bold
so now let's go back to our browser and
check it
so let me proceed without entering the
last name it says invalid here
so this was a simple demonstration to
show you form validation
of course you can modify the code
depending on your requirement
say suppose the length of the first name
is too short then you can alert the user
with a different message or
suppose they have missed out on filling
a form field then you can again alert
the user so you can basically make use
of the nested if condition right now
just try and help you understand that
better let me just show it to you
now back in my html
file
instead of invalid let me have another
tag a paragraph tag
within which i make use of ng if again
now ng if
name dot errors
[Music]
dot required
is true
then i display the message
first
name
required
all right
and
if
the length of the first name is
[Music]
not 2
now the length of the first name is less
than 2 then i'm going to display another
message so let me just say
name dot errors
dot min length
if this is true then i'm going to say
sorry
short
first name
all right so let's save this and have a
look at the browser
when i proceed without providing the
name it says first name required
but when i type in one character it says
sorry short first name but if i type in
another character it accepts so i hope
this made you understand how form
validation
works so this was just a simple
demonstration again now i highly
recommend you explore these properties
and play around with these objects uh
trust me it's really fun
so i hope this tutorial helped you out
let's understand what exactly is
bootstrap
bootstrap is a powerful toolkit
basically a collection of html css and
javascript tools for creating and
building responsive web applications and
pages it is a free and open source
project based on github and originally
created by twitter
now to put it more easily bootstrap is a
giant collection of handy reusable bits
of code written in html css and
javascript
it's also a front-end development
framework that enables developers and
beginners to design quick and responsive
websites
now there are several advantages to
using bootstrap
to name a few bootstrap comes with a
responsive grid
you don't have to spend time working on
your
layouts bootstrap comes with its own
code for automatically resizing images
based on the current screen size
it also comes with different components
that you can use for your web page these
components could be navigation bars drop
downs progress bars thumbnails etc
it also offers excellent documentation
and is customizable
so bootstrap comes in extremely handy to
create responsive
user interface
so now before using bootstrap it needs
to be embedded into your application
so let's see how to embed bootstrap into
angular
now there are two ways to do it
first up is by using the bootstrap cdn
or the content delivery network
now this enables users to load css
javascript and images remotely from its
servers
the other method is to use bootstrap npm
bootstrap jquery and other packages and
frameworks can be installed via the
command prompt
in the tutorial that i'm going to be
showing you i've embedded bootstrap
using npm all right so i'm sure you only
understand the concept better when you
look at a demo
so let's go ahead and create an
application with the help of angular
bootstrap so in this tutorial what i'm
going to be showing is the creation of a
blog post
so uh let me show you what we're going
to be doing
so here i've created a simple
blog for simply learn and i've added the
simply learn logo i've also written a
few lines about simply learn and what
they offer
i've also mentioned their tag line
and when you scroll down you can see
that i've mentioned
the different courses they're offering
and when you click on the more info
button
it navigates to the official page that
gives you the overview for that
particular course
so this is for lean six sigma the same
for full stack web development
as well
and uh the same for the last one that is
cyber security
and finally i have added a simple video
here to just make it more
beautiful so i've added a simple video
and lastly i've also
linked our youtube channel so when you
click on the youtube icon
it will navigate to the
youtube channel
to our youtube channel here
all right so this is what we're going to
be creating
using angular bootstrap so i'm
hoping you're all ready for it so
without further delay let's jump in
so first let's find the template that we
want to use for our blog
so for that i'm going to just go ahead
and say
bootstrap
blog template
and i'm just going to click on the first
link that i get
and here
you can choose the template that you
like
so i'm just going to look for more
templates here
and the one that we are going to choose
is
oh yeah this one so which is small
businesses so you can go ahead and click
on that
you can then click on live preview
and once you do that
you can just
say view frame source
so here you can see that the html code
is available
it has the head section and then the
body section
so the head section consists of a lot of
meta tags
and then you have the title
and then you also have the css file
references
and then if you look at the body tag you
have different code for different parts
of the
ui there's code for navigation bar and
then you have page content code
heading row
call to action and all of that
and lastly you have the footer
so what we're going to be doing is that
we'll take all of the code and then
we'll have to create components for each
of it and then we'll include all the
components in our main
html file so that is the best practice
that angular uses so we're going to make
use of components
and you can also see that
when you scroll down you can see that
it has certain dependencies so here it
has the bootstrap dependency and then
you have jquery so we have to
download them
so we'll have to install them
uh and as mentioned earlier we're going
to be installing them with the help of
npm
so for that we'll have to head back to
our vs code here
back in my vs code i've created a
folder called angulardemo
and then i've also created a file called
demo components
and here
i'm just going to say cd
demo components
within which i'll say npm
install
jquery
[Music]
so this could take a while
and once you've installed jquery go
ahead and type npm install
bootstrap
all right so we've successfully
installed jquery and bootstrap
so now we need to add the references to
these javascript files to do that
go to your angular.json file
and here we have to add them in our
build section so here you can see we
have styles and scripts so in our
scripts array we define the relative
path to these javascript files
so these files are generally
stored in your
node modules so go ahead and
here you can look for bootstrap
here you go and
then in your dist file
and then click on js
and then you can see you have
bootstrap.min.js
oh well i'm sorry we need
bootstrap.bundle.min.js
so here
you can just right click and say copy
relative path
and back in my json file in my scripts
i'm gonna just paste it here
and make sure to
make it a path by providing by providing
forward slash
[Music]
all right and then the next thing we
need is the
jquery.min.js files so for that
again in our node modules you will have
to look for jquery so here there's
jquery and then click on dist
and then we have jquery.min.js
so again let me just
copy the path
and paste it here
[Music]
follow the same procedure for this as
well
[Music]
all right so we've embedded both our
files in our angular.json file
so now in our code here
in the beginning they've also included
the css file
so we'll have to embed that as well so
here back
in
bootstrap
let me just add the css file as well
that's
bootstrap.min.css i'm just going to copy
the relative path
and just provide it here
[Music]
let me just change these
to forward slash
[Music]
okay so we have our custom style sheet
so what i'm gonna do is
i'm just gonna copy this
and just paste it in our
and then you can just paste it here
all right
so i think we've added all the
dependencies
and the custom style sheet and
everything so now let me just
close all of these files
what we can do now is that we can go
ahead and
take the code from the
source here so i'm just going to copy
the body tag
all right
so
i'm going to copy this till the footer
and then i'm just going to paste it in
my
component.html file
[Music]
so as mentioned earlier i will create
components and then place the code for
specific parts of the ui in these
components
so
let me just see if i've got everything
here
okay
so i'll be creating four components the
first one will be for the navigation bar
the second will be for the introduction
and then the third one will be uh to
display the courses that we're providing
and then lastly we'll have the footer
component
right so first let's create these
components i've also created a
components folder here in my app folder
so i just have to
type in the command
ngc
first we'll create
the
component for the top navigation bar so
i'm just saying nggc so i'm just gonna
say components
[Music]
slash nav bar
[Music]
all right so uh the component has been
created so what i'm going to do is i'll
just
copy this
[Music]
and paste it here
[Music]
all right and the next component i'm
going to be creating is for
the introduction right so i'll say ng
g
c
[Music]
components slash
intro
all right so
so i will have to take
this code here i'm also going to be
including the call to action part
so i'll just
copy paste this one in my
intro.html file
let me do that and then i'm going to
have the
main course content
component so for that i'll say nggc
components slash courses
[Music]
and we're going to copy the next part of
the code
[Music]
all right until
till the footer
[Music]
let me just add it here
and finally we're going to create the
component for the footer so
i'll say ngc
components slash
footer
and the last part of the code i'm just
going to add it there
[Music]
all right
so now we'll have to create the custom
html tags for these components and then
place it in our html file right so first
one that we created was the navigation
bar so here
head over to the ts file
just copied the selector
[Music]
and then here
and then in our
app.component let me just
create the tags
similarly for intro
[Music]
just gonna copy the selector
[Music]
and then for courses so
yeah app hyphen courses
that is well
and then lastly we have the footer
component so let me just copy that
paste it here
[Music]
all right so we've included all the
components so let's just run this
application and see if everything
is displayed intact
so here let me just say ng
serve so when you execute the command
you can see that the template is being
displayed so you have the navigation bar
you have the
intro component and then we have the
courses component and finally we have
the footer component right okay so now
that we have the template ready we can
go ahead and customize it according to
our needs so now i'm going to be making
a few changes to the code we're going to
add the simply learn logo we're going to
change the tag line here we're going to
display something else over here all
right so let's go back to our vs code to
customize
and display the final output
so here
the first thing that i'm going to be
doing is
changing the message here i'm going to
display simply learn for that
in our navbar component
let's go to the html code
and here instead of start bootstrap let
me just type in simply learn
[Music]
all right
so when you save it and when you look at
the browser
you can see that
simply learn is displayed
and the next thing that i want to do is
i want to add the image right i simply
learn logo so what i've done here is
i've already added
the logo
dot png file in my assets folder
so i'll just go ahead and provide the
path to this
so that's going to be in our intro files
so here
image source
is going to be
[Music]
assets slash
[Music]
logo.png
so let me save this
so there we go the logo is displayed
so the next thing is we'll have to
change
this part of the ui so the information
that i want to display is this
i'm going to be displaying
walls number one online boot camp and
other information so what i'm going to
do
is back in my vs code i'm just going to
delete
this
and instead of that i'm just gonna
copy this that's world's number one
online bootcamp
and then within the paragraph tag i'll
display something else so let me get rid
of this
[Music]
let me just copy the information that i
want to display
paste it here
and let me just give a line break
[Music]
let me save this and see if it's
displayed
so yeah we can see that the information
is being displayed
next up here instead of displaying call
to action message i'm going to display a
explore programs message so let's go
back to our vs code
let me just say explore
programs here
and then
lastly
instead of this message here
i want to display the message uh get
certified get ahead without programs
so back in rvs code
i'm just going to get rid of this
[Music]
and paste this instead
so when you
have a look at the browser
let me refresh this
you can see it displays the message get
certified get ahead and all of that
well now what i'm going to do is i'm
really not happy with the font size and
everything so i'm just go ahead and add
certain styling you can customize this
and provide your own font size and all
of that
so here i'm just going to mention style
and then say font
size
and i'm going to make it x x large
all right so let's see
[Music]
yeah all right so it's the font size has
increased so i think i'm happy with this
all right so the next thing we have to
do is add information here for our
courses
so back in our vs code
we'll have to go to the courses
component
so here i'm going to just uh type in the
code for the different courses so i
already have it here
so the first thing is this message that
i want to display let me just copy that
and for our first tag i'm just going to
say
postgraduate program ending six sigma
and the next information i'm going to be
providing is the duration
so here
let me just get rid of this
paste that here
let me just break the line
to beautify the
code
and then
and here for our
reference link i already have the link
here
so i'm just going to paste that so once
you click on the
more info button it will automatically
navigate to this page
all right
so let me save this
next up i'm going to do the same for the
other two courses as well
so it says post graduate program in
full stack development
and then we're going to mention the
duration and the cohort so
let me paste that
and also
provide a blind break
and then
link i have it here so
i'm just going to paste that
[Music]
and finally for the third card
i have
the third link here
[Music]
let me get rid of this extra core and
paste this instead
[Music]
and then let's also provide the link for
the same
[Music]
all right
so let me save this
and have a look at the browser
so you can see that uh the information
has been added
you can see it displays postgraduate
program in lean six sigma full stack
development and cyber security so once i
click on more info it leads you to that
page
that shows the overview all right
so now the next thing on the agenda was
to uh display a short video and then the
link to our youtube channel so let's go
ahead and add that in our
courses component
uh so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to get the code to add a video
from google and then i'm going to
provide the source
which is going to be the video that i
would want to display
so i've received the code i'm just going
to paste it here
so you can get the code uh on google so
go ahead and just paste that
also for the source i have a video in my
assets folder which i have provided here
so when i save it and look at the
browser here we go you can see the video
here
all right
and once clicked it starts playing
[Applause]
[Music]
all right and lastly we'll have to
provide the logo for youtube and then
the link to navigate to the youtube page
so let's go ahead and do that
so here again i've pasted the code
for the youtube logo so here you can see
that i've added the image that is
youtube.png in my assets folder and i've
provided the source and accordingly i've
also added
the styling i've provided a white
background and i've also aligned the
text to the
center of the page
all right and i've also displayed the
message saying check out our youtube
channel for technical videos and
tutorials
and then i've provided the link to our
channel on youtube
so let me just save this and head back
to the browser
and here you can see that
we have the youtube logo
and we have the message displayed
so once you click on the
logo it navigates to the simply learn
channel on youtube
all right so uh if you want you can also
change the message here for the footer
so here in
footer.html i can just
remove this and
paste this i say simply learn solutions
and all rights reserved
when i save it and look at the browser
it must get updated
so yeah there we go
so with the help of bootstrap we have
successfully created a website which is
basically a blog
and we've also added the reference links
and images and logos to customize it
according to our requirements
so yeah this is it this is how you make
use of bootstrap and embed it into your
angular
for more responsive and better user
interface let's have a look at the
basics of routing
now i'm sure that you observed that the
url changes every time you click on a
particular link or on an icon on the
user interface correct now this
basically indicates that you are
navigating throughout the application
now to achieve this navigation we use a
mechanism called routing routing is
essentially used to navigate through a
website or a web application
but how is it achieved in angular
especially in angular routing plays a
major role it is used to create single
page applications
now these applications are loaded just
once and new content is added
dynamically
applications like google facebook
twitter and gmail are a few examples of
single page applications the best part
of using single page applications is
that it provides an excellent user
experience and you don't even have to
wait for new pages to load which by
extension makes single page applications
extremely fast but how is this new
content loaded
enter routing now routing is the
mechanism that as discussed earlier that
is used to navigate through the
application and load new content
routing helps angular configure the
route and the component that needs to be
displayed
now i'm sure you're going to understand
the concept of routing better when you
work on it hands-on
so in the demo we're going to be
navigating to the login and the home
pages of a web application with the help
of routing
so let's head to our visual studio code
so basically the objective of our
application
is to navigate to home
and the login pages
so when i click on the login icon here
it loads the login
page
and here you can see the extension
slash login and similarly with home once
you click on it
some new information gets added and the
url changes
with the slash home appended
all right so this is the main objective
of our application so to create it let's
head back to our vs code all right so
here i've created a folder called demo
and underscore angular and i've created
a file called demo routing
now the first thing you want to do is
open the index.html file and make sure
that the base tag is added
now although this is generally
added when your app is created if it is
not then add a base tag with href
attribute which is set to a forward
slash
all right now this is generally done to
tell angular to construct the url while
navigating with a forward slash all
right and the next thing you want to do
is open your
app.module.ts file
and check if the app routing module has
been imported
if not go ahead and import it and then
also mention it in your imports array
with that the initial setup is done
now to create the nav bar the code that
i'm going to be using is already
explained in the previous video that is
angular bootstrap i highly suggest you
go through that video before watching
this
so the code is already available i'm
just going to create a component and
write the code for it
and paste the code in it so let's do
that
let me say
nggc
nav bar
[Music]
all right so this component is now
created
now here in my html file
i'll just get rid of this and paste the
code for the nav bar
so here we go i've pasted the code for
the navigation bar
and back in my
app.component.html file
i'll just remove all the
unwanted
code here
and just specify the
custom html tag for my navbar
so
let me just create one here
all right let me save this let me just
run the application and see if it's
displaying correctly
all right so when i open the browser
the navigation bar has been created
along with
these different options that's home
about services and login
all right and we also have the simply
learn icon here all right now the next
step is to generate the components to
display the login page content and the
home page content
now again i have used bootstrap to
define the user interface for these
files you can easily find the code
online just search for
bootstrap login templates and depending
on your requirements you can choose the
appropriate one
so first let's create
the components for my two files that is
for the home component
and the login component
so
let's go ahead and do that
[Music]
ngc
i'm just going to call it login for my
login component
all right and then i'm going to say nggc
home
for the home component
all right
so i'm just going to copy the
code for the login component
so back in my login.html
file
i'll just paste the code here
okay
also note that i've added the simply
learn logo in my assets folder
and then just provided the source for it
here in my login component
all right so next up is the home
component
and if you've seen the previous video
that is angular bootstrap you might have
seen that we created three different
components that is intro courses and
footer which included the content for
the intro message for the courses and
the footer message correct so here we're
going to just paste the code for all of
these three
and then just display it when the home
button is clicked
all right so what i'm going to do is
i'll just
paste it here
[Music]
so this basically has all the content
one thing i want to tell you is that in
the previous video we made sure that the
code was written in three different
components however for this i've just
added all the code in the same component
now i agree that this is not the best
practice so if you want you can go ahead
and create three different components
and
separate the code into these three
components and just add the custom html
tags in your home component
i'm just hoping you're following me
right now
and also here in my assets folder i've
added
a video and the youtube logo that needs
to be displayed
when the home icon is clicked
all right so now that we've created the
home and the login components the next
step is to configure the routes for the
application
right so here you can see that we have a
file called app routing module.ts file
so here
we have the routes and the router module
that is imported
and we also have a constant called
routes which is strongly typed to routes
from the router package
all right now this array is used to
define all the possible routes in the
application now each route is basically
an object with a path
so here in my routes array
i'm just going to go ahead and create
the paths that is we have two different
routes right one is for login and one is
for home
so i'm just going to create a path
object so let's say path
sorry within curly braces i say path
[Music]
and then the path that i'm going to give
is
login this is basically what will appear
uh on the url
all right
and the component that needs to be
navigated to is nothing but the login
component
so let me just say login
component
as you can see the login component has
been automatically imported
now same with
the home path so let me just say
path
home
and the component that needs to be
rendered is the home component
[Music]
all right
now the next step is to link these
routes to a button
in the nav bar that is the home and the
login button right so we're going to
make use of the nav tag and an anchor
tag for this
you can see that we have a nav tag
and an anchor tag
which encloses the login and the home
components
all right now we're going to make use of
two directors
from the router package called router
link and router link active
now these are specified within the
anchor tag
the router link basically holds the path
to the page
and the latter that is the router link
active specifies one or more css classes
that will be applied when the router
link is active
all right so to do that let me just
add
router
link
all right in our case it is home here
and we're going to have another
director called
router link active
[Music]
and we're just going to save
active here
[Music]
all right
same for the login icon here
let me just copy this
[Music]
and
instead of home
the path we created for this was login
[Music]
all right
so this is how you can bind the route to
your specific button on your ui
now despite of all this
how are we specifying where these
components are to be displayed
right the answer to this is using the
router outlet directive now again this
directive is available in the router
package
so we have to add that in our app
component.html file
so here just go ahead and type
router
outlet
all right so with that we've created a
simple navigation bar which has
different options that is home about
services and link and once the user
clicks on the home icon it displays the
content that is in the home component
homecomponent.html file
and once the user clicks on the login
component it displays the content in the
login.html file
all right it's as simple as that
so now let's go to the browser and see
if it executes correctly
so all right we have the navigation bar
and once i click on the home i can hear
all right yes we see that all the
content has been loaded
you can see we have uh the intro section
we have the courses section and the
footer section as discussed
and the most important part is that here
in our url you can see that slash home
has been appended this shows that a
route has been created that navigates to
the home component so we've successfully
created a route here
and for login component when i click on
this icon
you can see that the path changes here
and the login component gets displayed
all right so this is how routing is
achieved in angular
and with that we come to the end of this
session
if you have any doubts or queries
regarding this topic let us know in the
comment section
so thank you so much for being here and
watch out for more videos on the angular
series until then keep learning and stay
tuned to simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here